I think the thing about globalization is
its unevenness it's not a its people
always assume it's a fact it's not as
again as I said earlier you know people
business people who assume globalization
is just there and its net is never going
to go away should go and read history
books very quickly because it the
answers it can get reversed in the end
globalization relies on political
decisions it relies on tariffs being
down it relies on people being in goods
being able to cross borders and just to
give you a sort of frightening jumping
and what happens if there is a dirty
nuclear bomb in Delhi or and there was
Manhattan you know what would that do to
shipping stuff around the world people
be far more paranoid it's those sort of
things which could could get unstable it
that the underlying bits of
globalization I mean the which I think
you have to look at it as broadly as
possible i see globalization of you know
ever freer movement of goods capital
people but also ideas around the world
and that is generally why you know we
are we are hope hope a kind of great
liberal newspaper that is why we've
always been sort of Foursquare behind it
and for us it so you know economic
freedom and individual freedom they
don't absolutely go together but they
come from the same source
I think they're well there are lots of
dance eyes in a sense of individual
people who get caught out by this kind
of often a cruel process I'm a
particular group of people who have
always been vulnerable have tended to be
the workers in richer countries who are
more vulnerable to foreign competition
you shouldn't push that too hard I mean
if you look at most most things there's
been a lot of the big arguments recently
about wages in America you know why have
wages and where I could get down and
globalization is usually figured as the
culprit and that's you know mess the
evidence is no it's not the real thing
which has kept wages down as technology
and the problem is that it's very hard
for a politician to blame computers for
people's jobs going or for pressure on
wages it's much easier to say it's the
Chinese or the Indians but again you
know look just just think through your
your life you need to think that the
difference between banks when there were
lots of tellers and now the fact you
have atms to go and get stuff right that
they had a colossal effect on industry
far greater than sane after which
remember was sort of going through at
roughly the same time and after
attracted all the headlines and that's
that's the problem with globalization
that the basic economic logic of it is
always disturbed by the politics of how
it's how it's pushed forward